so let's talk about voting by mail very
important issue in general very
important issue acutely so right now
because of the corona virus pandemic I
have for you today exhibit a about why
Donald Trump is scared to death and
completely opposed to the November
presidential election being done as a
vote-by-mail election and the reason is
very simple vote by mail means more
people vote more people voting is not
good for Donald Trump and it is
generally not good for the Republican
Party the example comes from Kansas
Kansas Democrats decided to do this
year's primary or caucus as vote-by-mail
this is the Democratic selection in 2016
Kansas voted in person and about 39,000
people voted 39,000 in 2020 because of
the pandemic it's vote-by-mail and they
have already had 138,000 people votes
and this is considering that the outcome
is a foregone conclusion Joe Biden is
the only candidate left everybody else
has dropped out bernie's gone and still
with vote-by-mail this year we have a
turnout in Kansas that is three and a
half times that of 2016 there's almost
nothing to vote for in a sense and
turnout is orders of magnitude greater
than what it was in 2016 so we know that
vote by mail in November of 2020 would
be a turnout boosting mechanism we know
that even pandemic aside I mean just in
a normal election letting everybody vote
vote by mail would likely increase
turnout and that's not good for
Republicans and that's not good for
Trump why do you think they've spent 20
years trying to reduce the number of
people that are voting now there are
some other factors here which could
account for this huge rise in the number
of people voting in the Democratic
caucus in Kansas one is you know maybe
there's a motivation to vote against
Donald Trump in November for Democrats
and it's motivating some of them early
particularly because of the incompetent
response to coronavirus so you've got a
lot of fired up Kansas Democrats who
whose enthusiasm
voting in November is being reflected in
that they are also participating in the
Democratic primary that's possible
that's possible but these are massive
numbers again three and a half times
already the total turnout from 2016 and
Trump recently sang on multiple
occasions he doesn't want vote-by-mail
remember this get back to what you were
saying yesterday about people going to
Wisconsin and voting yeah in the middle
of this pandemic really putting their
lives on the line and you said well if
they do that vote by mail perhaps we'll
have voter fraud in this country it's
one of that abusive voters in five
states you talk Colorado Hawaii
Washington and Oregon all vote by milk
can you or the White House staff where
your campaign provide any evidence to
back up your claim the mail-in voting is
white with broad like the example you
gave of people working your rooms
filling out a false balance what
happening is this administrator and
where's the evidence the I think there's
a lot of evidence but we'll provide you
with some okay and as evidence that's
being compiled just like it's being
compiled in the state of California
where they settled with Judicial Watch
saying that a million people should not
have been voting in you saw that did you
weigh excuse me well I'm just telling
you I'm telling you in California in the
great state of California they settled
and we could have gone a lot further
so Trump with no real answers there
because the reality is vote-by-mail is
not going to dramatically increase fraud
and then previously here's Donald Trump
admitting that some of these ideas that
Democrats have like vote-by-mail these
would mean Republicans don't win which
may be true in the sense that the more
of the will of the people that's
represented at the ballot box the less
likely maybe it is that a con man like
Donald Trump would be able to get into
the Oval Office take a look your
strumpet mitting it just two common
facts I mean they have a majority in the
House and therefore you need their vote
and they want to get certain things I
will tell you this if you look at before
and after the things they had in there
were crazy they had things and levels of
voting that if you ever agree to it
you'd never have a Republican elected in
this country again
levels of voting which if you had would
mean a Republican never gets elected
again this is what is being talked about
and we are seeing it in Kansas and
Republicans know I mean let lets to
their credit Republicans aren't wrong
they know that if it's easier to vote
it's not good for them they know that if
there is less friction if there are
fewer obstacles if the barriers to entry
to voting are lower it's not good for
them because the will of the people will
be more accurately represented by a
larger share of the population of the
United States we are seeing an example
of it here all the policy that
Republicans are pushing when it comes to
how elections are done is about
suppressing the vote imagine the damage
that vote-by-mail would do to Republican
efforts to suppress voting not because
of fraud not because of dead people
voting not because of any of that stuff
simply because a larger share of the
population is casting a ballot so when
you look back at the last 15 years 20
years I mean you know and redistricting
gerrymandering has been going on for a
while but when you look at voter ID
efforts to reduce early voting efforts
to reduce the number of polling places
efforts to purge voter rolls voter
intimidation at polling places
constantly fear-mongering about almost
mathematically non-existent double
voting voter for in-person voter fraud
all of that stuff plus the
gerrymandering we now understand why and
it's very very clear all of a sudden
vote-by-mail would be devastating to
Republicans and potentially to Donald
Trump and so that's why they're going to
do everything they can to stop it now
let's talk about strategy a little bit
this matters more in swing states and
what I mean by that is whatever happens
between now and November California is
not going to vote for Donald Trump
they're going to vote for Joe Biden
whether it's vote by mail
whether it's voting in-person turnout
may be depressed if it's voting in
person and the virus is raging okay
California is not going to be a
difference maker we have an electoral
college system if Massachusetts votes by
mail or not Trump's not going to win
here in Massachusetts the important
states are
the ones that are always important in
the system that we have we're talking
about Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania
North Carolina Florida the places that
could turn the election from Trump to
Biden or vice versa
that's where we need to be working extra
hard to get vote-by-mail who is it going
to be up to well it's ultimately going
to be up to each individual state it's
going to be up to the governor it's
going to be up to the state legislatures
in those states this is why once again
local elections matter when you look at
many of the progressive successes of the
20th century
what made sure that those reforms stuck
was having a Supreme Court that would
uphold them that's called doing the
groundwork and much the same way what
could be the factor I mean I don't
believe it's hyperbolic to say that the
November of 2020 election could hinge on
is there a Republican or democratic
governor is there a Republican or
democratic state legislature if it
ultimately hinges on do they get to vote
by mail or not those are decisions that
we can go back to when the state
legislatures were elected to when the
gubernatorial elections happen this is
why every election matters and has to be
taken seriously
Republicans are scared the numbers in
Kansas tell us exactly why they should
be scared have you ever wanted to learn
to play the guitar but you've had
trouble committing to the time and money
required to actually take lessons I have
the perfect solution for you it's called
fender play it's an app developed by the
iconic guitar company fender it lets you
learn to play your favorite songs in
minutes on your schedule with
interactive video lessons that are very
easy to follow you can use it for guitar
bass or ukulele I've been using fender
play to learn the ukulele I've gotten a
lot better than I thought I would in a
couple of months I had tried teaching
myself using some YouTube videos didn't
really get any where night and day
difference since I've started using
fender play and they have personalized
learning paths that will cater to your
musical tastes you can use it on your
phone tablet or computer and you learn
at your own pace which is just awesome
one year of membership gives you access
to thousands of lessons
for less than the cost of one
traditional in-person lesson and when
you go to fender dot-com slash Pakman
you'll get to try it totally free for
two whole weeks free two week trial
don't lose out on that without any
commitment that's f en de our comm slash
Pakman PA que ma n fender dot-com /
Pakman